herzlich willkommen zum Wohnungsprojekt
Nummer 8 dem Projekt in dem ich eine
Wohnung kaufe sie rausreiße renoviere
und nach meinen und euren Träumen umbaue
ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
nach einer sehr aufregenden Zeit in der
wir ein 10 Folgen starkes behind the
scenes zu seven vs world Staffel 2
gedreht haben wo übrigens die erste
Folge am Sonntag kommt kann es jetzt
endlich im Wohnungsprojekt weitergehen
aber vor allem brauchte ich erstmal
Zugang zur Wohnung den hatte ich nicht
mehr weil ich alle Schlüssel zur Wohnung
an verschiedene Gewerke gegeben habe ein
bisschen weiter gearbeitet haben während
ich im Ausland für die Produktion von
Seven vs white war ziemlich dumm alle
Gewerke die den Schlüssel hatten sind
über die Herbstferien in den Urlaub
gefahren ich stand da und bin in meiner
eigenen Wohnung nicht mehr reingekommen
musste den Schlüsseldienst anrufen das
Schloss austauschen lassen
Hammer unnötige Kosten aber wir waren
drin und konnten weitermachen vier ganze
Wochen war ich im Ausland und habe mich
die ganze Zeit darauf gefreut hier
endlich wieder weitermachen zu können in
der Zwischenzeit wurde das komplette
Badradio gemacht es wurde fugenlos
gespachtelt von einwandfrei Jungs haben
richtig abgerissen es sieht hammergeil
aus das werdet ihr diese Folge aber noch
nicht zu Gesicht bekommen denn heute
kümmern wir uns als allererstes darum
die komplette Wohnung fertig zu
spachteln noch ein bisschen Trockenbau
zu schleifen zum Malern und diese
Wohnung hier scheinbar zum ersten Mal
wirklich wieder bewohnbar zu machen viel
Spaß wir brauchen haftputz Gips den habe
ich schon geholt wir brauchen einen
Spachtel einen Mörtel der sowas und wir
brauchen Löcher die wir machen können
davon haben wir glücklicherweise genug
danke an elektrowerk all das was die
Leute hier am Ende in der Wohnung
wirklich sehen und anfassen können also
die letzte Schicht das was wirklich
clean sein muss mache ich wie immer mit
Profis und schaue den später in diesem
Video noch ein bisschen über die Finger
dieser ganze Prozess ist so angesetzt
für ungefähr vier Tage ist Fertigstellen
der Wohnung ist tatsächlich angesetzt
für die nächsten drei oder vier Wochen
also hier geht ist jetzt wieder Schlag
auf Schlag der Schreiner macht im
Hintergrund alles was zu tun gibt erster
Kaliums warten nur drauf endlich die
Keramik einbauen zu können und im
nächsten Video bauen wir schon das
Parkett ein das Mischverhältnis nicht zu
nass und nicht zu trocken wie genau
keine Ahnung wir werden bisschen
rumprobieren Hauptsache so dass in den
Schlitzen kleben bleibt muss ich gut
anfühlen auf dem Spachtel sag ich mal so
ne das bringt doch schon nichts Alter
[Musik]
normalerweise ja immer noch nicht oh
Gott wir probieren es einfach mal also
fast so aus als wird das da drin halten
ist jetzt noch vernünftig macht ist die
Frage womit schmeiße ich das da besser
rein
ja ich sag mal so ne lieber schleife ich
am Ende noch mal ein bisschen aber mach
die Dinger hier fertig als dass ich mich
jetzt zu lange damit aufhalte was soll
ich Euch erzählen ach du scheiße
[Musik]
so ungefähr klar
geil tip top
[Musik]
muss reichen das hier ist Müll
so freut das alles geschafft es
mittlerweile dunkel geworden alle
Schlitze sind zu ganz gut funktioniert
ich bin mal gespannt was die Maler
morgen dazu sagen
Tag Nummer zwei es geht weiter ich habe
natürlich verschlafen und den Trockenbau
nicht gemacht bevor der Profi gekommen
ist von der Firma Bosbach unterstützt
mich heute es wird hammer geil und
während der jetzt die Wände vorbereitet
hier alles noch ab macht was ich
vergessen habe abzumachen dann schleift
und so weiter bastel ich hier am
trockenbaubeit
erklären muss ich euch zu Trockenbau ja
nichts mehr nachdem wir dieses Büro hier
in wochenlanger Arbeit aufgebaut haben
ich in der letzten Folge den Trockenbau
schon angerissen habe glaube ich ist das
genug gecovert auf diesem Kanal da ich
ja absoluter Trockenbau Profi bin nach
dem Meter weisen wenden die ich bis dato
gezogen habe sollte das alles kein
Problem sein und ich starte einfach mal
[Musik]
Pascal ist jetzt schon dabei
patrick ist jetzt schon dabei die Kuchen
vom Trockenbau zu verspachteln ich
kümmere mich jetzt darum die Wände
vorzuschleifen und damit vorzubereiten
dass wir heute schon die erste Schicht
verputzen können was richtig geil werden
danach werden wir hier alles nicht mehr
wiedererkennen jetzt gerade sieht noch
alles scheiße irgendwie so ein bisschen
gelb aus und danach wird der komplette
Raum hier schon richtig weiß sein so
arbeiten wir uns Stück für Stück hin zu
perfekten Wänden auch wenn die Wände
hier einfach nicht perfekt werden können
wenn ich schon nicht professionell
arbeite dann will ich wenigstens
professionell aussehen
[Musik]
und kein Witz wir haben aus irgendeinem
Grund vier Tage hintereinander
vergessene Box mitzunehmen aber auch da
wussten wir uns zu helfen und haben
einfach angefangen zu singen
ich spachteln haben wir uns für fertige
Spachtelmasse entschieden die ist ein
bisschen anfängerfreundlicher weil ich
sie aufgetragen habe zumindest als
erstes mit der Rolle patrick hat die
dann glatt gezogen und so konnten wir
ziemlich schnell quadratmeterweise uns
Vorarbeiten und die gesamte Wohnung
spachteln das hat richtig gut
funktioniert und wenn ich das jetzt noch
mal selber machen würde selber
ausprobieren würde nachdem ich jetzt so
grob weiß wie es geht würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch wieder fertig
gespachtelmasse nehmen das was ihr hier
hinter mir seht ist eine zumindest zum
ersten Mal gespachtelte Decke es sieht
krank aus
und während wir da so Friede Freude
Eierkuchen am Arbeiten waren hat Patrick
einen Anruf erreicht mit dem wir erstmal
nicht so richtig wussten umzugehen
[Musik]
oder was das heißt Polizei anrufen und
egal
Handyvertrag damit abgeschlossen weil
ich glaube dann können wir [ __ ] Alter
limited Max für 60 € und für ein Handy
dafür was im Endeffekt passiert ist
jemand hat sich mit Patricks geklautem
Ausweis auf dem Weg in ein
Elektronikmarkt gemacht und dort
probiert drei Verträge mit dem neuesten
iPhone 14 pro abzuschließen also mit
seinen Daten irgendwas zu kaufen und
weil sowas nicht nur offline sondern
auch online unheimlich oft passiert und
ein reale Gefäß wird das heutige Video
freundlicherweise vom nordvpn
unterstützt deren Service über die
Videobeschreibung nur ein Klick entfernt
bei einer man in the middletech bei der
jemand in einem öffentlichen Netzwerk
beispielsweise in einem Café eure Daten
abgreifen könnte um damit beispielsweise
drei neue Handyverträge abzuschließen
werdet ihr mit nordvpn sichern da sie
eure Daten verschlüsseln egal ob das
Netzwerk sicher ist oder nicht allgemein
ist nordvpn essentiell um dauerhaft
sicheres Surfen zu garantieren und euch
weniger angreifbar für schädliche
Software und Mehrwert zu machen das
Beste daran ist aber dass ihr euch bei
nordvpn dank Nord links mit
gleichbleibender Geschwindigkeit
absichern könnt außerdem hat er
natürlich weiterhin Zugriff auf alle
eure Liebling Inhalte auch wenn sie in
eurem Land eigentlich gar nicht
verfügbar sind und dazu habt ihr die
Möglichkeit mit nordvpn Streaming
Anbieter zu einem günstigeren Preis zu
bekommen checkt das ganze jetzt über den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
über
www.nordvpn.com/vpn ab und sichert euch
den exklusiven Deal für den 2 Jahresplan
und bekommt so noch 4 Monate gratis
nordvpn oben drauf das ganze könnt ihr
dank 30 Tage Geld zurück Garantie
komplett risikofrei testen vielen Dank
an nordvpn dass sie dieses Video und
Projekt möglich machen checkt das
Angebot ab und viel Spaß weiter mit dem
Video
20 Uhr ganzen Samstag durch geballert
die komplette Bude ist fertig also nicht
ganz fertig aber wirklich krank was
heute abgerissen haben richtig gute
Basis gesetzt Montag geht's weiter
Dienstag werden wir hoffentlich fertig
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich sagen
soll ich bin dann
Tag Nummer 2 wir sind wieder da ist
alles soweit ganz gut angetrocknet die
Decke haben wir schon geschliffen jetzt
geht's ans tapezieren also
Tapetenkleister an die Decke Tapete ran
und dann mit so einem Rakel die Tapete
glatt machen komplett an die Decke oder
Wand anfügen und Luftblasen und
Lufteinschlüsse dann noch raus dingsen
um alle Unebenheiten auszubessern und
das in fast jedem Schritt gibt es so
einen großen Schleifer der ist direkt an
einen Staubsauger angeschlossen und mit
dem kann man super entspannt super
entspannt über Kopf ist immer so eine
Sache aber ziemlich entspannt große
Flächen machen das natürlich super
wichtig wir wollen nicht nur dadurch
dass wir Sachen auftragen ein möglichst
glattes Ergebnis Zeugen sondern direkt
von vorne rein so rein starten also
alles abschleifen in Geschichte drauf
abschleifen wieder eine Schicht drauf
und so weiter das ist ein step der uns
eigentlich über den gesamten Prozess die
ganze Zeit begleitet hat parallel dazu
kommt jetzt mein liebstes Lasermessgerät
wieder zum Einsatz ich messe jetzt noch
einmal ganz genau wie lang die Wände die
ich selber gezogen habe und wie breit
und so alles ist damit wir mit der
Lichtplanung parallel beginnen können es
wieder elektrogirk mit systemics
supportmäßig dabei der kriegt jetzt
gleich die Daten von mir und fängt dann
an die komplette indirekte Beleuchtung
auszumessen und in Auftrag zu geben wenn
die komplette Bude wird im Bad und im
Wohnbereich indirekt beleuchtet das wird
hammergeil und das werdet ihr dann in
einem späteren Video sehen wo es um
komplette Multimedia Technik Licht und
weitere Finale Elektrosachen geht
Tag Nummer 3 wir sind zurück in der
Wohnung heute wird gestrichen erste
Schicht ist schon drauf die zweite
Schicht mit absoluter Premium Farbe dem
reichsten weiß dass wir finden konnten
wir gerade aufgetragen
am Ende die Leute wirklich sehen werden
aber es sieht schon unglaublich geil aus
drei Tage arbeiten
gerade noch die letzten Sachen weg
stehen in der fertig gemahlerten Wohnung
ist die unglaublich aus es ist so ein
viel krasseres Raumgefühl einfach es ist
viel mehr Platz es ist viel heller und
in den nächsten Tagen kommt der Boden
schon rein in der nächsten Folge
erwartet euch ganz großes tatsächlich
ist der Boden schon drin der Schreiner
ist dabei die Einbaulösung zu
finalisieren es geht jetzt wirklich
schlag auf schlag ich schätze das in den
nächsten drei Wochen das komplette
Projekt fertig wird am Sonntag kommt
schon die erste Folge seven vs right
beyond the scenes ich habe zwei Leute
extra neu eingestellt damit wir das
irgendwie gewuppt bekommen wir sind 12
bis 14 Stunden am Tag am Arbeiten mit
vier Leuten fulltime an diesem Projekt
es wird das Größte was jemals auf meinem
Kanal gab ich entschuldige mich vielmals
das in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
etwas weniger kam das ganze aber
wirklich mit gutem Grund dieses während
des Dienst dieses Projekt wird alles
sprengen das ist einfach noch mal ein
ganz anderes Level ich freue mich extrem
darauf euch das zeigen zu können das
wird richtig richtig fett und wir haben
riesige Sachen für die kommenden Monate
und fürs nächste Jahr geplant seid euch
sicher wenn ihr am wenigsten von mir
hört mache ich am meisten wir sehen uns
in den nächsten Tagen schon wieder macht
es gut bis dann